control 20 minutes the chair recognizes
the gentleman from new york
here i ask unanimous consent that all
members have five legislative days to
revise and extend
their remarks and include extraneous
material on h.r 1651
so ordered without objection
the gentleman from new york is
recognized thank you madam speaker man
of speaker i yield myself such time as i
may consume
the gentleman is recognized and as
speaker
h.r 1651 the covet 19 bankruptcy relief
extension act of 2021
his bipartisan legislation to
temporarily extend until march 27
2022 the covet 19 bankruptcy relief
provisions
enacted as part of the cares act and the
december 2020 omnibus appropriations
bill
since the bankruptcy provisions of the
cares act will expire next week
it is urgent for congress to ensure that
families and small businesses
do not lose access to these economic
lifelines
these provisions were enacted last year
to provide critical relief to families
and small businesses forced into
bankruptcy
because of the ongoing
for example they help ensure that
federal coded related relief payments
are used by families to get through this
pandemic instead of being seized by
creditors
they also help people stay in their
homes and ensure that their utilities
are not shut off
in addition these provisions protect
individuals and creditors alike
from the effects of the pandemic
derailing the court-ordered repayment
plans that promise a way out of
chapter 13 bankruptcy
excuse me they will also allow more
small businesses to take advantage of
the streamlined process
established by the small business
reorganization act
extending these necessary protections in
mark until march of next year
will provide much needed certainty that
the bankruptcy system will remain
responsive to debtors and creditors
alike
during this extraordinarily disruptive
crisis
i thank mr klein for his work with me on
this bill and for his work to ensure
that small businesses have meaningful
access to the bankruptcy process
i urge my colleagues to support this
urgently needed bill
and i reserve the balance of my time the
gentleman from new york reserves
the gentleman from california
thank you madam speaker i yield myself
such time as i may consume
the gentleman is recognized madam
speaker
this pandemic everyone knows has
uprooted lives and caused
untold destruction to families to
workers into small business
and many see the partisan behavior
as destructive during this time and they
often do not see the bipartisan behavior
today's extension h.r 1651
is an example of bipartisan behavior on
behalf of the american people
repeatedly lengthy government shutdowns
in response have
to the pandemic have devastated the
ability of millions to work
pay bills and support their families and
keep
their small businesses afloat in my home
state of california
the restaurant industry has seen more
than one out of four
restaurants shuttered their doors
forever
in 2020 congress passed five bipartisan
cover coveted relief packs the cares act
allowed a variety of temporary measures
for families and small businesses
when it was passed we believed that in
fact
once the vaccine was available that we
would be able to put this behind
us but today when over 10 of americans
have received the
vaccine we now know that the road
to full recovery is longer ahead of us
even after we begin going to work so
allowing small businesses to file
chapter 11 bankruptcy by increasing the
maximum debt ceiling
excluding of federal covert relief
payments from
income calculations and allowing debtors
to file
chapter 13 to modify their payment plans
or only some of the
critical items that the cares act did
and that today we are making sure will
continue until
march of 2022. this bill also extends
through 2022
bankruptcy relief provisions included in
the december
2020 covet relief bill a package
the extension will provide individuals
and businesses with
certainty simplicity as they
look at an economic recovery that
although it is underway
may be long
enacting this bill will assist debtors
and businesses of all sorts
as americans and their firms continue to
address economic realities
the bill is bipartisan and the bill
recognizes that even
businesses which have remained up and
running
often find themselves in a ripple effect
of other bankruptcies or failures by
companies that have been shut down
and so i strongly
recommend the passage of this bill and i
reserve the balance of my time
the gentleman from california reserves
the gentleman from new york
reserve the gentleman from new york
reserves the gentleman
from california thank you madam speaker
i now
am pleased to yield three minutes to one
of the co-authors of this bill the
gentleman from virginia mr klein
the gentleman from virginia is
recognized thank you madam speaker i
thank the gentleman from california my
friend
working on this issue i want to thank
the chairman for his uh
work on this issue great leadership on
on this important
initiative in 2010 the national
bankruptcy conference small business
working group released and presented to
congress a report that identified a
problem regarding small businesses in
the bankruptcy law
and recommended amendments to the code
to add a new chapter for small business
reorganizations
as a result of this recommendation
introduced the small business
reorganization act which was signed into
law of august
in august of 2019 and i'm pleased to say
it's been a good
great success for small businesses it's
my understanding that eighty percent of
small business debtors have chosen to
proceed
under sub 5 and preliminary data
indicates that these cases
are achieving confirmation far more
often than small businesses who filed
prior to sbra however the small business
reorganization act was implemented only
a month before
the covet 19 pandemic caused the state
mandated temporary closure
of thousands of businesses and so seeing
the need to ensure that this new
lifeline would be
even more impactful the cares act passed
in march of 2020
increased the amount of debt a business
can have to be eligible for small
business
bankruptcy procedures from 2.7 million
to 7.5 million
and allowed debtors experiencing
hardship because of covet 19
to modify bankruptcy reorganization
plans entered into before the law was
enacted
i've heard from bankruptcy judges and
lawyers in the western district of
virginia
who have said that their experience with
the small business reorganization act
has been
extremely positive and according to the
american bankruptcy institute as of last
sunday
1 651 cases have been filed
in addition according to federal
judicial centers integrated database as
of september 30th 2020
there were 759 subchapter 5 cases filed
in the six months
from the time the debt limit was raised
to the end of fiscal year 2020
with information on liabilities
available for 548 of these cases
of those 28 percent involved debtors
whose liabilities exceeded the original
limit
of 2.7 million and these debtors would
not have been eligible for subchapter 5
without the temporary increase provided
by the cares act and without this bill
to keep the debt limit at 7.5 million
for another year
while we continue to navigate this
pandemic about 30 percent of businesses
who would choose to use it
would no longer be eligible preservation
of the business benefits
both the creditor who should receive a
higher recovery
because of the debtors restructuring
than they would if the business
liquidated
and the debtor who will now be able to
remain in business rather than
liquidating
our districts depend on their small
businesses their hotels convenience
stores restaurants and pharmacies
those who endeavor to open and run a
small business are proud of their work
and their standing in our communities
unfortunately they also take on a
sometimes insurmountable financial
burden
and as we've seen over the last year
when they're forced to close it has a
great impact on the rest of us
that's why the year and spending and
relief package omitted recovery rebate
payments from bankruptcy estates and
blocked utilities from stopping or
denying service to some individuals in
bankruptcy this bill would extend those
provisions by three months
but wouldn't affect other provisions in
that law that are already scheduled to
expire later in
2022 i'm proud to have introduced this
legislation along with the chairman
chairman nadler to support our small
businesses
and our family is recognized i'm proud
to have introduced this bill with the
chairman
and i urge this passage i yield back
the gentleman from california reserves
the gentleman from new york
madam speaker i have no further speakers
gentlemen reserves the gentleman from
california madam speaker
we have no further speaker speakers so
in closing
both sides of the aisle are united
behind this
good sensible extension of law
and we strongly recommend that all our
members vote for it
and i yield back the gentleman from
california yields back the gentleman
from new york
mr speaker this bill will provide
critical relief to the small business
and families forced into bankruptcy
because of the ongoing pandemic these
provisions help make sure that the
pandemic does not
derail the path to a fresh start to the
bankruptcy code promises for individuals
and businesses
alike as mr isis said
this is bipartisan legislation i am
aware of no opposition
to it whatsoever i hope all my
colleagues will support this urgently
needed bill
and with that i yield back the balance
of my time
new york yields back and the question is
will the house suspend the rules and
pass bill
h.r 1651 as amended
those in favor say i
those opposed say no
in the opinion of the chair two-thirds
being in the affirmative
purpose there's a gentlewoman from
georgia madam speaker i request the yeas
and nays
soon to section three s of house
resolution eight
the yeas and nays are ordered pursuant
to clause
8 of rule 20. further proceedings
on this question are postponed
for what purpose does the gentleman from
new york seek recognition
madam speaker i move to suspend the
rules and pass h.r 1652
the vote of fix to sustain the crime
victims fund act of 2021 as amended
the clerk will report the title of the
bill h.r
1652 a bill to deposit certain funds
into
into the crime victims fund to waive
matching requirements
and for other purposes pursuant to the
rule
the gentleman from new york mr nadler
and the gentleman from california
mr isa each will control 20 minutes
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
new york
thank you madam speaker i ask unanimous
consent
that all members have five legislative
days to revise and extend their remarks
and include extraneous material
on h.r 1652 so ordered
madam speaker i yield myself such time
as i may consume the gentleman from new
york is recognized madam speaker
the voca fix to sustain the crime
victims act
the crime victim's fund act would
support vital victim service programs by
preventing future cuts
to already diminished federal victim
service grants
grants unto the victims of crime act or
voca
are the primary source of federal
funding for thousands of victim service
providers around the country
including programs serving victims of
domestic violence
sexual assault child abuse trafficking
and drunk driving
vocal grants also fund victim
compensation
including paying medical bills covering
lost wages and paying for funeral costs
these critical grants are not taxpayer
funded
instead they are paid out of the crime
victims fund or cbf
which is funded and turned through
federal criminal fines
forfeited bail bonds penalties and
special assessments
collected by u.s attorney's offices
federal u.s courts and the federal
bureau of prisons
over the past several years however
deposits into the cbf
have dropped significantly leading to
corresponding cuts and grants to victim
service providers
this is in part because the federal
government has increased its reliance in
recent years
on deferred prosecution and
non-prosecution agreements
the penalties from which are not
deposited into the cv
this legislation would shore up funding
for this critical fund
by requiring doj to deposit penalties
from these deferred prosecution and
non-prosecution agreements
into the cvf in addition to the funds
currently deposited from other sources
not only does this legislation ensure
that the cvf is more financially stable
it would also make much needed
improvements to victim compensation and
services
for example it would increase the
statutory amount awarded to victim
compensation programs
and it expands the range of victims
eligible for compensation
it also allows states to request the no
cost extension
from the attorney general as allowed for
other department of justice formula
grant programs
to ensure that states can thoughtfully
and effectively distribute victim
service grants
without being penalized other
improvements include waiving matching
requirements for the duration of the
covitt 19 crisis
plus one additional year an additional
discretion for the states
which administer voca funds to further
wave matching requirements once this
initial waiver period expires
all of these provisions would
substantially improve the program's
effectiveness
and would enable it to offer more
services to more people
i want to thank the gentleman from
pennsylvania mr fitzpatrick
the gentlelady from queens ms jackson
lee and the other bipartisan co-sponsors
of this important legislation for their
support i also want to thank our
colleagues in the senate including
senator durbin
the lead sponsor and senator graham for
their efforts to pass the bill
in that chamber as well this bipartisan
bicameral legislation
ensures that programs and services
assisting victims of crime
are fully funded and are better
supported with no new taxpayer dollars
i urge all my colleagues to support this
legislation and i reserve the balance of
my time
gentleman bringing from new york
reserves the gentleman from
california recognized thank you madam
speaker and i yield myself such time as
i may consume
madam speaker so often we hear
criminals should pay for what they've
done
wrong this is exactly what the victims
of crime
act has done since 1994 is to provide
the ability to collect fines and fees
against those very perpetrators and
apply it
toward the solution and in fact the
remediation of the damage they have done
no amount of money makes up for the
crimes they've committed
but certainly this goes a long way today
we are dealing with the
tendency within the article two within
the executive branch
when money is available to see if they
can't move it to where they would like
to spend it
rather than the clear intent of congress
i'd like to thank
chairman nadler and congresswoman
wagner for their work on making sure
that this bill does just that
it puts the money back where it was
originally intended
for instance voca supports shelters for
victims
of domestic violence which affects more
than 12 million adults each year
vocal funding is also used to support
services for victims of child abuse
and sexual assaults in all more than 6
000 organizations
nationwide are funded through this act
however because funding has fluctuated
and at times have been diverted
by the department of justice this in
fact
will both increase and stabilize those
funds
over the years congress has suggested
fund funding flowing in
and out of this account with an attempt
to create certainty
for support for these programs
unfortunately we haven't always
succeeded
and i am not without some recognition
that today
will not be the last time we come back
to say congress
on a completely nonpartisan basis really
means that
these penalties and fines need to get
to the organizations that deal with the
victims
today's bill will do just that and we
stand
on a bipartisan basis ready to ensure
that we do that again
once again i would like to thank the
chairman
and congresswoman uh wagner and all the
others that work so diligently on this
bill and i
reserve the balance of my time the
gentleman reserves
the chair now recognizes the gentleman
from new york uh man i speak right now
you have three minutes to the
gentlelady from texas mrs jackson lee
ladies recognized i thank the speaker
asked unanimous consent to
address the house for the period of time
given
the general the gentlelady is recognized
across america we can hear the cries of
those who have been victims of crime
it is not in any way distinguished by
communities or race
age sex it prevails our
society i'm reminded of the tragedy of
two brothers
on a crime spree killing a man and
kidnapping a woman
those are victims of crimes their
families are victims of crimes
and i can assure you that we stand
collectively as members of congress
recognizing that voca is crucial
to responding to restorative justice for
victims
the federal grants used to support
victim services through vodka have it
decreased significantly over the past
several years
further drastic cuts to volca funding
are expected as the non-taxpayer-funded
pool from which these grants originate
the crime victims fund is running dry
i'm delighted to be an original
co-sponsor with chairman nadler
mr fitzpatrick scanlon and to have
worked with
congresswoman wagner over the years on
this very important legislation
further drastic cuts to vaca are
expected as the non-taxpayer-funded pool
from which these grants originate
the crime victims fund is running dry
the crime victims fund serves as an
example of true justice because the
money
used to support victims comes not from
taxpayer dollars but rather
from the criminal fines and penalties
paid by federally convicted offenders
the crime victims fund has shrunk
rapidly in recent years
and continues to decline because rather
than prosecuting cases
the department of justice increasingly
settles cases through deferred
prosecution and non-prosecution
agreements
and the monetary penalties associated
with these agreements are deposited
in the treasury rather than the crime
victims fund
we don't want to pit one form of reform
against
one great need these agreements may
diminish the ability of vodka to be
funded
because of the lack of dollars going
into the fund
the crime for which these penalties are
derived are the same whether they are
prosecuted or settled and the funding
should be given to serve victims the
vodka fix act of 2021
fixes this by ensuring that monetary
penalties
associated with deferred and
non-prosecution agreements
go into the crime victims fund instead
of into the treasury
common sense victims are outcrying
their need for relief this simple fix
will prevent
future funding cuts that jeopardize
programs abilities to serve their
communities and will help address
the many growing and unmet needs of
victims and survivors including
survivors of domestic violence
we'll be on the floor tomorrow with the
opportunity to vote
on the reauthorization of the violence
against women act
there are countless examples in domestic
violence stalking
sexual assault sex trafficking that
shows that victims are in need
victims are elders victims are young
victims are families victims are mothers
and fathers
we are doing so because we recognize the
urgency
and our ladies time has expired the
gentleman uh yield an additional minute
i yield the gentlelady in additional
minute the gentlelady is recognized
i thank you the dire need faced by
victims and survivors throughout this
country during
a pinnacle moment caused by the pandemic
the numbers of domestic violence have
gone up in cities like houston san
antonio port
uh in oregon states like oregon and new
york
and we should recognize that the
cooperation
of this uh legislation in terms of
improving the funding
is absolutely crucial the vodka fix of
2021
survivors of domestic violence sexual
assault will inevitably lose
access to victim support services
leaving victims and survivors without
options for safety and vulnerable
opportunities to help them in their
victimization
if we don't fund this and change this
process
so the vodka fix will rebuild lives
it will save the lives of children who
have been impacted by
violence against their family members
and yes uh
it will be the fair assessment of
justice that is what we're here to do
fair arbiters of justice so i ask my
colleagues to support this legislation
and to join us tomorrow to support the
violence against women act
to recognize that it is our job to
promote justice
in this place i yield back
the gentleman reserves the chair
recognizes the gentleman from california
thank you madam speaker it is now my
pleasure to yield
five minutes to the general lady from
missouri who has done so much on this
bill
miss wagner it is recognized
i thank the gentleman from california
for yielding me the time a good friend
um in congress for years we're so glad
to have you back mr chairman
thank you also for leading this
legislation along with
so many others madam speaker i rise in
support
of h.r 1652 the voca fix to sustain the
crime
victims fund act i am proud to co-lead
this
critical legislation which will ensure
that
victims of serious crimes can continue
to access
the services that they need to heal
and rebuild their lives
victims of crime act or voca grants
are the primary source of support
for programs dedicated to survivors of
domestic abuse
sexual assault trafficking
child abuse and other very traumatic
crimes these grants are funded by
federal criminal monetary penalties not
not by taxpayers however
with the department of justice
increasingly seeking
non-prosecution and deferred prosecution
agreements
instead of prosecuting federal crimes
boca grants are
facing catastrophic cuts
in my own home state of missouri
we are expecting a 25 cut
to vocal funds in the upcoming year if
and if this bill is not signed
into law missouri law enforcement
and victim service providers along with
prosecutors
need congress to enact this legislation
so they can protect and care
for their communities if we do not act
swiftly
to stabilize the vocal funding thousands
of americans will be unable to access
life-saving services and these programs
have
never been more important
that pandemic has put women
and children in particular at an
increased risk of abuse
and domestic violence we cannot leave
victims without
support during frightening
and vulnerable times this bipartisan
and bicameral legislation which is why
i'm also hopeful that
when the senate passes this mr chairman
madam speaker we will have the
opportunity
to actually make this law so this
bipartisan and bicameral legislation
will help those victims
recover as our justice system prosecutes
the criminals
responsible i am grateful
that the house is taking swift action to
secure services for victims
and i again urge my colleagues to
support
the victims of crime fix
act and i yield back the gentlewoman
appeals
the gentleman madam speaker in closing
uh i urge passage of this bill recommend
that all members vote yes and i yield
back
the gentleman yields back the gentleman
from new york mr speaker will close now
last year all 56 state and territorial
attorneys general sent a letter to
congress
warning us that the balance and
financial health of the crime victims
fund is in jeopardy and urging that we
act swiftly
to address the problem they explained
any decrease in the funds available for
distribution results in a decrease
in the number of victims and survivors
that are served as well as potential
loss of essential staff of victim
service programs
the vocal fix is sustained the crime
victims act heeds their call
and would ensure that this fund has the
resources it needs to continue
delivering essential services to
victims of crime this important
legislation is supported by more than
sixteen hundred and seventy national
regional state territorial local
organizations
i want to thank all my colleagues who
have supported this bill
uh i am aware of no opposition to this
bill
at all and i urge all of my colleagues
to support it
i yield back the balance of my time the
gentleman yields back
the question is will the house suspend
the rules and pass the bill
h.r 1652 those in favor say
1652 as amended
those in favor say aye those opposed no
in the opinion of the chair two-thirds
being in the affirmative
the gentleman from georgia madam speaker
asks for the yeas and nays
pursuant to section 3s of the house
resolution 8
the yeas and nays are ordered pursuant
to clause 8 of rule 20
further proceedings on this question are
postponed
chris for what purpose does a
gentlewoman from california
seek recognition madam speaker by
direction of the committee on rules i
call up house resolution 233
and ask for its immediate consideration
the clerk will report the resolution
house calendar number 11 house
resolution 233
resolved that upon adoption of this
resolution it shall be in order to
consider in the house the bill h.r 1620
to reauthorize the violence against
women act of 1994 and for other purposes
all points of order against
consideration of the bill are waived
an amendment in the nature of a
substitute consisting of the texas rule
committee print 117-3 modified by the
amendment printed in part a
of the report of the committee on rules
accompanying this resolution shall be
considered as adopted
the bill as amended shall be considered
as read
all points of order against provisions
in the bill as amended are waived
the previous question shall be
considered as ordered on the bill as
amended
and on any further amendment thereto the
final passage without intervening motion
except one
one equally divided and controlled by
the chair and ranking minority member of
the committee on the judiciary or their
respective designees
two the further amendments described in
section two of this resolution
three the amendments on block described
in section three of this resolution and
four
one motion to recommit section two after
debate pursuant to the first section of
this resolution
each further amendment printed in part b
of the report of the committee on rules
not earlier considered as part of
amendments on block
pursuant to section 3 of this resolution
shall be considered only in the order
printed in the report
may be offered only by a member
designated in the report
shall be considered as read shall be
debatable for the time specified in the
report equally divided and controlled by
the proponent
and an opponent may be withdrawn by the
proponent at any time before the
question is put thereon
shall not be subject to amendment and
shall not be subject to a demand for
division of the question
section three it shall be in order at
any time after debate pursuant to
the first section of this resolution for
the chair of the committee on the
judiciary or his destiny
to offer amendments on block consisting
of further amendments printed in part b
of the report of the committee on rules
accompanying this resolution
not earlier disposed of amendments on
block
offered pursuant to this section shall
be considered as read
shall be debatable for 20 minutes
equally divided and controlled by the
chair and ranking minority member of the
committee on the judiciary or their
respective designees
shall not be subject to amendment and
shall not be subject to a demand for
division of the question
section 4 all points of order against
the further amendments printed in part b
of the report of the committee on rules
accompanying this resolution or
amendments on block described in section
3
of this resolution are waived section 5
upon adoption of this resolution it
shall be in order to consider in the
house to bill hr6
to authorize the cancellation of removal
and adjustment
of status of certain aliens and for
other purposes
all points of order against
consideration of the bill are waived
an amendment in the nature of a
substitute consisting of the text of
rules committee print 117-4
shall be considered as adopted the bill
as amended shall be considered as read
all points of order against provisions
in the bill as amended are waived
the previous question shall be
considered as ordered on the bill as
amended
and on any further amendments thereto
the final passage without intervening
motion except one
one hour of debate equally divided and
controlled by the chair and ranking
minority member of the committee on the
judiciary or their respective designees
and two one motion to recommit section
six
upon adoption of this resolution it
shall be in order to consider in the
house the bill h.r 1603
to amend the immigration and nationality
act to provide for terms and conditions
for
non-immigrant workers performing
agricultural labor or services
and for other purposes all points of
order against consideration of the bill
are waived the amendment printed in part
c of the report of the committee on
rules accompanying this resolution
shall be considered as adopted the bill
as amended shall be considered as read
all points of order against provisions
in the bill as amended are waived
the previous question shall be
considered as ordered on the bill as
amended on
and on any further amendment thereto
final passage without intervening
mission except one
one hour of debate equally divided and
controlled by the chair and ranking
minority member of the committee on the
judiciary or their respective destinies
and two
one motion to recommit
section 7 upon adoption of this
resolution it shall be an order to
consider
in the house the bill h.r 1868 to
prevent
across the board direct spending cuts
and for other purposes
all points of order against
consideration of the bill are waived
the bill shall be considered as read all
points of order against provisions and
the bill
are waived the previous question shall
be considered as
ordered on the bill and on any amendment
thereto to final passage without
intervening motion except one
one hour of debate equally divided and
controlled by the chair and ranking
minority member of the committee on the
budget
or their respective designees and two
one motion to recommit
section 8 upon adoption of this
resolution it shall be in order to
consider in the house a joint resolution
house joint resolution 17 removing the
deadline
for the ratification of the equal rights
amendment all points of order against
consideration of the joint resolution
are waived
the joint resolution shall be considered
as red all points of order against
provisions and the joint resolution are
waived
the previous question shall be
considered as ordered on the joint
resolution
and on any amendment thereto the final
passage without intervening motion
except one
one hour of debate equally divided and
controlled by the chair and ranking
minority member of the committee on the
judiciary
or their respective designees and two
one motion to recommit
section 9 house resolution 232 is hereby
adopted
section 10 notwithstanding clause 7 of
rule 10
during the 117th congress the period
described in such clause
shall end at midnight on april 22nd
the gentlewoman from california is
recognized for one hour
madam speaker for the purposes of debate
only i yield a customary 30 minutes to
the gentlelady from minnesota pending
which i yield myself such
time as i may consume during
consideration of this resolution
all time yield it is for the purpose of
debate only
i ask unanimous consent that all members
be given five legislative days to revise
and extend their remarks without
objection madam speaker today the rules
committee met and reported a rule house
resolution 233 providing for
consideration of h.r 1620
under a structure rule the rule self
executes a manager's amendment by
chairman adler
makes an order 41 amendments and
provides unblock authority to chairman
nadler
the rule also provides for consideration
of hr6
hr 1603 and h
j rest 17 under close rules
the rule provides one hour of debate
each equally divided and controlled by
the chair and ranking member of the
committee on the judiciary for their or
their designees
for h.r 1620 hr6 h.r 1603
and eight and h j rest 17.
the rule provides one motion to recommit
on each bill
the rule also self executes a manager's
amendment by chairman aller
for hr 1603
the rule provides for consideration of
h.r 1868
under a closed rule it also provides one
hour of debate equally divided
and controlled by the chair and ranking
member of the committee
on the budget or their designees finally
the rule provides that h.r
232 is hereby adopted and extends the
deadline for the committee funding
resolution until april 22 2021.
thank you madam speaker we are here
today
to protect the vulnerable among us
to strengthen the foundation of our
democracy
and ensure humane working conditions for
the people
who feed america we're here to live up
to our best ideals as a nation by
creating protections against some of the
worst threats
that a person can face threats like
domestic violence in the minute that
i've been talking
20 people in this country have been
abused
by their partner by the time we're done
tonight
that number will be over a thousand
as someone who worked as a 911
dispatcher for nearly 18 years
as someone who has been on the other end
of the line
for domestic violence as someone who has
heard gunshots
silenced a young girl screams for help
i'm telling you the thousand people
victimized while we're here tonight
need and deserve our help
and that's exactly what the violence
against women's app does
it makes vital new investments in
prevention
it strengthens essential protections for
the most vulnerable among us
including immigrant lgbtq
and native american women and it
improves service
services for victims it prevents abusers
and stalkers from getting firearms and
much
much more vawa is one of many vital
protections
we will discuss today but it isn't the
only one
madam speaker this september will mark
100 years
since the amendment was first was first
proposed
for our constitution to guarantee women
equal rights with men
it finally passed congress in 1972
this simple amendment reads in part
equal equality of rights
under the law shall not be denied or
abridged
is being held up on a technicality
a technicality stakes took
so long to sign on that the arbitrary
deadline
that was set by congress this body
has passed even as 38 states have
ratified
the amendment congress
created this problem and congress must
fix it
hjr 79 will remove the deadline for
ratification and finally allow
us to ensure women are treated as equals
to men
in our democracy
the need for equal rights under the law
is not
debatable too often
we have seen the results of unfair and
unequal policies for women
this bill will help end those injustices
and as we strive to make our nation a
more perfect union
then we need to consider how we treat
immigrants too
immigrants are the invisible backbone
of this country they are our family
members
our neighbors our front line workers
women into every aspect of the american
fabric dreamers grew up in our
communities
they pledge allegiance to our flag
they played in our fields prayed in our
churches
and worked in our stores
they want to contribute to the only
nation
that they've ever called home the dream
and promise act helps them do that
it creates a pathway to citizenship for
our dreamers
and it updates our temporary protected
status and defer
and force departure laws to prevent
devastating deportations
the fact is too often
the contributions of aspiring americans
are left out of our dialogue
about immigrants but this pandemic
has put a spotlight on just how vital
that they are
without immigrants working our fields
your last meal
would have looked much different without
them
enduring record setting temperatures
facing threats of wildfires
and doing it all without proper ppe the
price you paid to feed your family
would go way up deaths among latino
farmer farm workers increased by 60
percent during the pandemic
they are sacrificing their lives to feed
us and the question is
what are we willing to do in return
the farm workforce modernization act
creates a pathway to legal status for
more than a million farm workers
and addresses our future labor needs by
modernizing
our outdated system for temporary
workers
this bill will give farm workers the
dignity
and recognition they deserve while
giving our farmers the stability they
need to run
their business now before i move on to
another topic i want to say something
about my personal immigration story
just like many of our dreamers i was
sent here by my parents
to escape the violence
my family faced in guatemala
i know exactly what it's like to decide
between the violence
and poverty of staying or the dangers
and unknowns of trying to immigrate here
what i know is that we cannot legislate
a solution for immigration
when we ignore the factors that drive it
strong men narco traffickers
have taken a hold in central america
and the rule of law is under assault
the organizations that once fought to
hold corrupt actors accountable
have been dismantled and their former
employees
are now being pursued by those very same
corrupt actors
attorney generals unfortunately
our asylum seekers in our own country
we don't just have a responsibility to
help stabilize the region
it is imperative that if we are ever to
stop the rush of people
trying to come here
i will close by saying every policy
i described today is a policy i'm truly
proud of
and just like the american rescue plan
did last week
democrats are making clear
with our actions exactly
what our priorities are it doesn't
matter how good our agenda
is if we can't deliver on the bills we
pass
the one thing standing in our way right
now
is an inside the beltway term called pay
go
and we and if we don't address it now
it will trigger massive cuts it goes
without saying that this
would be a completely unacceptable
at a time when americans are
in urgent need of more support
not less republicans passed legislation
in 2017 to avoid pay goal
in order to provide tax cuts for the
filthy rich
so they clearly understand
the need to avoid draconian cuts and i
expect them to join us
in preventing them h.r 1868 the final
bill
we are here to discuss today will do
exactly that
and i look forward to a fruitful debate
on those
on these bills and with that i reserve
madam speaker the gentlewoman reserves
the gentlewoman from minnesota is now
recognized
madam speaker i thank my colleague from
the rules committee the representative
from california for yielding me the
customary 30 minutes
and i yield myself as much time as i may
consume
so recognized madam speaker i rise in
opposition to the rule
a continuation of the democrats weeks
long
partisan push to fulfill the partisan
wish list
first up is h.r 1620 the violence
against women reauthorization act which
is a highly divisive distortion of the
original violence
against women act that will jeopardize
the safety of women
by extending services to men who
identify as women
and allowing them to utilize programs
that were designed to protect vulnerable
women
the bill puts the safety of women at
risk the bill expands the definition of
domestic violence
to include economic and emotional duress
driving needed resources away from
combating violent crimes against women
and promoting an unproven restorative
justice approach
instead democrats have told us again and
again
that it is time to rethink our approach
to law enforcement
but the same democrats who want to
defund the police
are now pushing this unfunded mandate to
the tune of hundreds of millions of
dollars
upon law upon law enforcement
that doesn't help anyone next is hj
resolution
res 17 which removes the established
deadline for the ratification of the
equal rights amendment
as the deadlines for states to ratify
era has long passed the
constitutionality of this legislation
is suspect at best congress does not
have the authority to simply extend the
deadline
some four decades later i also have
concerns about this amendment
radicalizing gender to enshrine
pro-abortion rights in the constitution
i do not need a constitutional amendment
to tell me i am equal
the constitution and federal law already
require
equal protection for all americans
but if my colleagues on the other side
were serious about the equal rights
amendment
they would ensure that the process for
adoption was done entirely by the book
rather than saying good enough as they
move forward in this questionable manner
next hr6 the dream and promise act of
2021
will provide amnesty to millions of
illegal immigrants
incentivize illegal boarding crossings
and worsen the surge of illegal
immigration we are currently seeing
the bill will provide green cards to
criminal aliens at a time
when the southern border is already
overwhelmed costing taxpayers hundreds
of billions more h.r 1868
addresses the very real budgetary
consequences of last week's
massive partisan spending package being
signed into law
well we can all agree that we should
avoid cuts to mandatory spending that we
have
that have been automatically triggered
by this level of spending
there was an opportunity to work across
the aisle on a bipartisan solution
it's unfortunate that the majority has
chosen once again
to forge ahead on their own with highly
partisan policies for this reason madam
speakers i urge my colleagues to think
twice
before supporting this rule we can do
better for the american people
and finally i want to address h.r 1603
the farm workforce modernization act
a bipartisan effort to reform our
agricultural
worker programs to address the workforce
needs of our agricultural community
well i appreciate the efforts of my
colleagues including my colleague from
the state of washington
congressman newhouse and others on both
sides of the aisles
go to negotiate in good faith on this
legislation
i will point out that this bill is not
without its flaws
it does not address the already high
costs of the h2a
program to make it more economic to make
a more economical solution
to producers it introduces a new private
right of action
against employers that risk costly
litigation that our producers cannot
afford
these types of issues are why
stakeholders such as the american farm
bureau
have concerns with this legislation make
no mistake
a viable workforce for our agriculture
industry
is a national security issue however i'd
like my colleagues
to recognize that with the current
language
this bill is not the end-all be-all
solution for our farmers and ranchers
while this legislation may pass the full
floor this week
as it stands i hope our counterparts in
the body
in the other body improve the bill
before it is sent to the president
with that mr madam speaker i urge
opposition to this rule and reserve the
balance of my time
the gentlewoman reserves the chair now
recognizes the gentlewoman from
california
madam speaker i yield four minutes to
the gentlewoman from texas miss jackson
lee
the gentlewoman is recognized i thank
the uh
manager of the bill for her leadership
and the rule
madam speaker i i asked to address the
house
for four minutes um let me
first of all rise in support of hr6
because there are millions of young
people waiting for this relief in the
daca promise
the american dream and promise act is
long overdue these are
nurses and doctors these are hardworking
young people these are college students
they're ready to serve america
let me also rise in support of the farm
workforce modernization act
for the many many farmers across america
that are supporting that and needing
that
and let me rise and i don't know who
would be against making sure that there
are no medicare cuts as we proceed to
give lifeline to the american people
through the american rescue act i stand
solidly behind that bill
but let me spend most of my time madam
speaker on the question
of the violence against women act and
1620
and h.j rez17 first of all
there is no divisiveness and i really
stand
openly against that interpretation
is there divisiveness on helping rape
victims across america
who as president biden has said they
live in states that are not blue states
or red states
but they live with the scourge of
domestic violence one of the most
dangerous calls that police officers
make
we have in the violence against women
act which i wrote in 2018 when we could
not get this bill to the floor
because our republican friends would not
proceed at that time
there was a republican president a
republican house and a republican senate
nothing happened and women suffered
my women's center right now is teeming
with women who are impacted by domestic
violence during this pandemic
they're crying out for this legislation
and they don't see
divisiveness what they do see is
enhanced legal assistance
what they do see is 110 million dollars
for rape prevention
what they do see is intervention with
cultural with training for men and boys
they see a cultural uh space that
provides culturally sisters training
and up and and uh uh refuge
for culturally uh distinct women who are
victimized
who can go in a quiet calm place and
deal with culturally sensitive
counselors and others
what they see is cooperation between
the victim and law enforcement by
providing and making sure
that they have the kinds of resources
and legal representation that is
necessary
no one goes without legal representation
whether they are immigrant
or native american they see an enhanced
response
to the victimization of native american
women who in fact there are those who
victimize them
on their uh particular reservation or
pueblo
and then run off uh outside of that and
they're not prosecuted we change that
they see the closing of the boyfriend
loophole they see the taking away of
guns from stalkers
yes this is a lifeline the violence
against women act constitutionally
grounded
due process protected for those who may
be accused
but it is legislation that women have
been waiting for
this bill expired in 2018 we wrote it in
2018 we built on it in the last congress
and the amendments that were both
republican and democrats
are still in this bill because we
believe in bipartisanship and it is a
bipartisan bill
with members from this conference a
republican conference who are in this
bill in terms of co-sponsors and then as
it relates to h
res 17 let me say that congress has the
authority
to extend the deadline for ratification
of the era
and the era says that women do not have
to live
uh in uh discomfort uh
and live under the equality and live in
inequality
they live in a nation of equality and
they live in inequality
in housing in income uh in access to
credit
in many ways in employment why are we
continuing this in the 21st century
so what does hj res do it extends
the deadline for the compliance
with the equal rights amendment for the
states
to be able to reach the 38 margin the
gentlewoman's time has expired
i will grant one additional minute
the gentlewoman is recognized for one
additional minute thank you so very much
and it extends that time uh beyond the
time that was last extended
when we extended that time we extended
it by majority vote in the united states
congress
a decision came out just recently about
the fact that the deadline had expired
but what it did say is that the deadline
was created by congress
and that congress obviously has that
authority when we researched this in
1978 in the judiciary committee
there was no requirement that that
extension of the deadline
constitutionally required
a two-third super majority vote simple
majority
are you going to suggest that women now
should be denied the era
when we have a number of states have
already
sanctioned this there are some states
that have rescinded
but that will be the jurisdiction of the
united states congress when appropriate
i asked my colleague to support vawa h.r
1620 and h.j red 17
removing the deadline for the
ratification of the equal rights
amendment
it is time for vawa it is time for the
era with that i yield back my time
that's the gentleman reserve i reserve
general reserves the gentleman woman
from
minnesota is recognized madam speaker i
yield three minutes to the ranking
member of rules the representative from
oklahoma
the gentleman is recognized thank you
very much madam speaker and i thank my
good friend and the rules committee for
yielding
madam speaker i rise in strong
opposition to this rule
this rule and the accompanying
legislation sadly is not about passing
law
it's about making a point all five of
the bills dealt with in this rule
have not been marked up by any committee
in this congress
at all and all of them are filled with
poison pills that are designed to make
sure most republicans will not
vote for them and they cannot pass the
senate of the united states
the two bills dealing with illegal
immigration will not just help
people to daca people it will it will
legalize millions of people in this
country illegally
the measure on era the timeline ran out
for that 42
years ago this matter cannot be reversed
now frankly the matter dealing with the
budget as my friend from
minnesota suggested we said last week
you're going to run into this problem
you're going to cut
medicare there's billions of dollars of
wasted spending in that reconciliation
bill
that could actually offset those cuts we
should be considering that
let me turn now the violence against
women act madam speaker
i've been one of the strongest
supporters of that legislation since i
arrived in congress
and i particularly am pleased with some
of the measures dealing with native
american women particularly some of the
changes in this bill
that extend it to children and extend it
to tribal law enforcement
officers those are good changes but
there are other measures coupled with it
dealing with the second amendment
or dealing with frankly people that are
not biologically female that will put
this bill
at risk on this floor and certainly in
the united states senate
madam speaker none of this was ever
designed to become law
two years ago we made that mistake three
years ago actually a little over
two years ago in 2018
and none of the good things happen let's
not make that mistake again
let's reject this rule let's modify
these bills
let's send the senate something it can
work with and pass
if we do that we have a chance not of
making a point
but of actually making law that benefits
every single american
with that madam speaker i yield back the
balance of my time gentlemen yields
the gentlewoman reserves the gentlewoman
from california is recognized
madam speaker let the records show that
oklahoma's
fourth district has 146
168 eligible medicare beneficiaries
that will be harmed if hr 1868
does not pass let the records show that
minnesota's seventh district
has 152 451
eligible medicare beneficiaries that
will also be harmed
if hr 1868 does not pass
and for the record i would like to
request unanimous consent to insert into
the record an october 18
2019 usa today article entitled
one in three american indian and native
and alaska native women
will be raped but survivors rarely find
justice on tribal lands
without objection and i reserve
gentlewoman reserves
gentleman from minnesota is recognized
madam speaker i yield two and a half
minutes to my good friend and another
colleague from the rules committee the
representative from pennsylvania
the gentleman is recognized thank you
madam chair and thank you to my
colleague representative fischbach for
the time
the role before us today provides for
consideration of hr6
a bill creating a pathway to citizenship
for millions of people
who entered this country illegally while
doing nothing to enforce our immigration
laws or secure our borders
you heard that right this bill does
nothing to enforce our immigration laws
it does nothing to secure our borders
and it does so as a record number of
illegal immigrants
poor across our southern border and yet
house democrats are passing a bill
that will further incentivize illegal
immigration
and will worsen the biden border crisis
the numbers speak for themselves over
100
000 migrants were encountered at our
southern border
just last month the cbp facility
in donna texas was at 729 percent
capacity last week
let me repeat that that facility was at
729 percent capacity
and alarmingly cbp confirmed that four
people were arrested at the border
three of whom were from yemen one of
whom was from serbia
and those individuals matched the names
on the fbi's terrorist
screening database so despite my liberal
progressive colleagues claim to the
contrary
this surge is directly the result of the
biden administration's decision
to halt the border wall construction to
re-implement
obama-era catch and release policies and
to cancel president trump's
asylum agreements this chamber should
work to address
the border crisis going on biden's
border crisis we should not pass
legislation
that encourages and rewards illegal
immigration
and further incentivizes this crisis
yet that is what hr 6 in fact does
this bill places the interest of those
who broke our laws
above the interest of those who followed
them
it has no enforcement provisions and
includes loopholes to give green cards
to gang members and criminals it even
puts u.s
taxpayers on the hook for grant programs
to help illegal immigrants
obtain green cards again 6 would do
absolutely nothing to address
president biden's border security and
humanitarian crisis
at the southern border i urge my
colleagues to vote no
on the rule and vote no on hr 6. with
that i yield back
the gentleman yields back the gentleman
reserves
the gentlewoman from california is
recognized
madam speaker the situation at the
border has nothing to do
with the dream and promise act if
anything
former president trump's attempt to
eliminate all resources
contributed to the crisis at the border
the dream and promise act does not apply
to future migrants just those who were
already
in the country before 2021.
this dream act has a very high criminal
bar
an applicant is disqualified if they
have
any one of the following a felony
conviction
one misdemeanor conviction involving
moral
turpitude more than two misdemeanors
or one misdemeanor for domestic violence
with that i reserve that a woman
the gentlewoman from minnesota is
recognized madam speaker i yield three
minutes to the representative from
missouri
the gentlewoman is recognized i thank my
friend
for yielding and madam speaker i rise
in stark opposition to h.j rez17 which
would retroactively
and unconstitutionally remove the
deadline to ratify the equal rights
amendment ratification of the equal
rights amendment
will expand taxpayer-funded abortions
and imperil
basic pro-life protections that states
have enacted
based on the will of their people
through their state legislatures
i am a committed defender of rights for
women
and girls and i have led efforts in
congress to end sex trafficking address
the rape kit
clog and help women balance staying in
the workforce and caring
for their children as a mother
and as a proud grandma i want
my sweet granddaughter to feel secure
and the knowledge that
she is entitled to the same rights and
opportunities
as men however i cannot support this
attempt
to circumvent the amendment process and
enshrine
access to taxpayer-funded abortion in
the constitution
by a simple majority vote rather
than with the required support of two
thirds of congress or the states
congress has twice given states time to
ratify the equal rights amendment
but the deadline has long since passed
while some states ratified the era after
the deadline
others up to five have withdrawn their
ratification
i strongly agree and associate myself
with the late supreme court
justice ruth bader ginsburg's words when
she made the point and i quote
if you count a late comer on the plus
side
how can you disregard states that said
we've changed our minds
if democrats want to test the
long-standing bipartisan agreement
on limiting taxpayer-funded abortions
they should
follow justice ginsburg's guidance and
start
the process over just as our founders
intended i urge my colleagues to oppose
this legislation
and madam speaker i'd also like to set
the record straight
when it comes to the violence against
women act or vawa
my amendment was removed
in a partisan fashion from
vawa this congress stripping
vital sex trafficking funding for
victims
for children this has always been
included and it was stripped
out and not allowed in the amendment
process
also not allowed was my prenda
amendment that would have stopped
selection sex selection in the womb
taking the lives of young girls
i urge opposition to this legislation
and to all
that you've seen before
i reserve gentlewoman reserves the
gentleman from california is recognized
madam speaker my colleagues across the
aisle are not supportive
of provisions to protect lgbtq
plus individuals in this bill
the lgbtq plus members of our community
experience domestic violence too
abusers do not discriminate
based on sexual orientation
and neither should this body
legislators who oppose equality
are trying to turn this into a debate
about abortion
to distract to distract from the issue
at hand
i would like to clarify that the era
doesn't include any requirement
to provide specific health care
services including abortion
it is about equality under the law
madam speaker i reserve gentlelady
reserves
gentlewoman from minnesota is recognized
madam speaker i yield one minute to my
good friend the representative from new
jersey
thank my friend for yielding the
gentleman from new jersey is recognized
thank you
madam speaker the most recent marist
poll found that seven
in ten americans including nearly half
who identify as pro-choice
want significant restrictions on
abortion yet the era is written will be
used
in an aggressive litigation strategy to
nullify those restrictions including
the height amendment waiting periods
parental involvement women's right to
know laws conscience rights
and the late term ban on abortion like
the partial birth abortion act
narrow pro-choice america has said and i
quote
the e.r.a would reinforce the
constitutional right to abortion
and require judges to strike down
anti-abortion laws
close quote the national organization
for women said
quote an era properly interpreted would
negate the hundreds of laws
that have passed restricting access to
abortion abortion activist madam
speakers successfully litigated
using state eras in both new mexico and
connecticut
to compel taxpayers to pay for abortion
on demand
last year justice ruth bader ginsburg
spoke on the legal impermissibility
of extending the deadline for
ratification and said that
we that we should start over
i couldn't agree more i yield back the
gentleman yields
i reserve the gentlewoman reserves the
gentlewoman from california is
recognized
madam speaker i ask unanimous consent to
insert
into the record a march 16 usa
opinion today opinion piece from
activists
dolores huerta carol jenkins and eleanor
smile entitled
there is no deadline on women's equality
add equal rights amendment to the
constitution
madam speaker kovit's impact on women
shows
the continued need for equality
we have the power to remove the era's
ratification deadline
and make it a reality
with that without objection to the
gentleman reserve
reserve the general reserves the
gentlewoman from minnesota is recognized
madam speaker i yield myself as much
time as i may consume
if we defeat the previous question i
will offer an amendment to the rule to
provide for consideration of
congresswoman miller meeks's
h.r 1897 the react act
and madam speaker i asked for unanimous
consent to insert the text of my
amendment in the record
along with the extraneous material
immediately prior to the vote on the
previous question
without objection to speak further on
the amendment i yield five minutes to my
colleague the representative from the
state of iowa
the gentlewoman is recognized thank you
madam speaker and i thank my good friend
congresswoman fishball for yielding
me time i urge my colleagues to defeat
the previous question so we can take up
my bill
h.r 1897 the react act
my bill would require the department of
homeland security to test all migrants
illegally crossing our border for
covid19
whom they plan to release into our
communities yesterday i traveled to el
paso texas to meet with the men and
women of the united states custom and
border protection
i saw firsthand the crisis they are
facing and believe it is our job as
congress to do everything in our power
to address it
cbp is currently encountering more than
3 000 migrants
on average per day which is rapidly
approaching levels seen at the height of
the 2019 crisis
to put this in perspective president
obama's secretary of homeland security
jay johnson
stated during his tenure that one
thousand apprehensions a day was
considered
a bad day we are at more than
three times that now and on top of it we
continue to face a global pandemic
in february cbp encountered over 100 000
migrants on the southwest border trying
to illegally enter our country
this does not include those migrants who
may have gotten away or evaded detection
some of whom may be positive for covid19
the department of homeland security
announced today that we are on track to
encounter the highest number of migrants
along the southwest border in the last
20 years
seasonally migration gets worse in the
spring months of april and may
so we are likely to see these numbers
increase over the coming months
yesterday i heard directly from the
border patrol agents that few if any of
the thousands of migrants we saw in cbt
cbp custody
are being tested for covet 19. these
migrants and children in particular are
being held in facilities
that are already at capacity and often
for longer than the 72-hour limit
permitted by law
according to recent reports as of march
8 185 migrants released into brownsville
texas have tested positive for covid19
border security and immigration is not
an issue that only affects border states
it affects every community across the
country if the biden administration
continues to release these migrants they
will not stay in our border communities
instead they will travel to every state
and without proper testing and
quarantine
and they are likely to bring coven 19
with them and
the communities to which they are
transferred are unaware
as a physician and the former director
of the iowa department of public health
i know that the coven 19 pandemic is not
yet over
we must ensure that any individuals the
vitamin
administration insist on releasing into
our communities
do not have covet 19. this is also why i
support reinstating the paws act to
prevent the introduction of new covet 19
cases from canada and mexico
for this reason i urge my colleagues to
support this legislation
to require that we keep all of our
communities
and these migrants safe and stop
spreading covet 19 by voting no
on the previous question thank you and i
yield back my time the gentlewoman
yields
madam speaker i reserve the gentleman
reserves the gentlewoman from california
is recognized
madam speaker president biden inherited
a dismantle and gutted immigration
system
the prior administration's strategy of
cruelty
chaos and confusion was ineffective
and set the stage for our current
challenges
i ask unanimous consent to insert into
the record
a march 15 columbus dispatch article
entitled undocumented immigrants pay
billions
in taxes each year and have been for 25
years objection madam speaker during the
last four years
millions of immigrants face uncertainty
under the trump administration
pursued cruel immigration policies
with passage of hr6 we are beginning
a new chapter in our nation's
immigration
policy that i reserve gentlewoman and
reserves
gentlewoman from minnesota is recognized
madam speaker i yield two minutes to the
representative from new york
the gentleman from new york is
recognized thank you madam speaker
and i will note in response to my
colleagues across the aisle that
there is nothing wrong with enforcing
the immigration laws that are on the
books and that's all we're talking about
doing at the border
and keeping the border secure madam
speaker yesterday i visited the southern
border
and what i saw was unacceptable full
stop i witnessed a dangerous and rapidly
growing impacts of biden's border crisis
i spoke to border patrol agents on the
front line of the crisis
and witnessed firsthand what they are up
against thousands of migrants are
showing up
every week hanging on to the words and
the promises of president
president biden's uh goal of relaxing
the border border issues
and border restrictions our border
patrol agents are under-resourced and
overwhelmed
they have been put in an untenable
situation with little regard for their
health or safety homeland security
secretary major has recently announced
the department would begin allocating
fema resources fema is the agency that's
in charge
with overseeing the pandemic and
delivering vaccines to our american
citizens
he's taken resources away from those
american citizens
to deal with this crisis on the border
if fema is involved it is by definition
a disaster last week senior health
homeland security officials told the
committee that customs and border patrol
doesn't have the capacity
to test and quarantine migrants in their
custody
and that there was no planning being
done to ensure migrants
are not released by the federal
government at the border if they are
coveted 19
positive thousands have been released
i saw with my own eyes hundreds of
people in this facility
not a single one was tested and we don't
know and only half the border patrol
agents
had been uh had been not inoculated
we don't know how many have cobit 19 and
quite frankly i don't think they want to
know
in the midst of the ongoing pandemic
it's the department's job to ensure it
doesn't release
anyone copin 19 positive for this reason
i support
efforts to defeat the previous question
and bring up common sense legislation
to require that any individual released
from a cbp or ice custom test negative
for coven 19. president biden's
knee-jerk reversal of productive
effective border security policies
from the previous administration was a
politician
madam speaker i yield an additional 30
seconds
thank you madam speaker president
biden's knee-jerk reversal of productive
effective border security policies from
the previous administration was a
political calculation that is quite
frankly backfired
and created humanitarian security and
public health crisis
we can't allow our nation's progress in
overcoming the ongoing pandemic
to be undermined by dangerous policies
allowing individuals of covet 19
to be released into our communities i
urge my colleagues to vote to defeat the
previous question
now you'll back the balance of my time
the gentleman yields
madam speaker i reserve the gentlewoman
reserves
the gentlewoman from california is
recognized
madam speaker i ask for unanimous
consent to insert into the record
a a statement by homeland security
secretary alejandro
and majorcas without objection
in which he states the many
issues associated uh with the southern
border
and what we are doing to address those
issues for example
border patrol facilities and border
personnel
that had not had complete access to
kelvin 19
now have complete access to the vaccine
it states about the disruptions of the
previous administrations and their lack
of commitment to deal with tender age
children
and many other issues that could help
inform
this conversation moving forward with
that
i reserve my time gentlewoman reserves a
gentleman from minnesota is recognized
madam speaker i yield two minutes to the
representative from new mexico
the gentlewoman is recognized thank you
madam speaker
i rise because i am concerned about the
release of aliens into my community
without coven 19 testing
dr miller meeks changes this to
legislation
are vital to protecting americans from
the spread of kova 19.
as our nation continues to deal with the
kova 19 pandemic our state is still
largely locked down our schools are
shuttered
and many of our businesses have been
closed due to orders from the state and
local officials
in many areas along the border cbp has
restarted catch and release in the midst
of this unprecedented pandemic
this is completely illogical especially
while american citizens
continue to live under such restrictions
in fact again
i can point to double standard madness
speaker
it is very unfair to think that we want
to do something to protect these
young families these unattended
unaccompanied children
when we know for a fact that they are
coming across the border at the age one
three and five alone without any
supervision
we know for a fact that they are being
raped and pillaged along the way
and if we feel like that somehow is a
benefit to the children
let alone being exposed and coming into
this nation with covet
then we are fooling not only ourselves
but again the american people
we aren't just putting the immigrants in
harm's way
but the american people we should be
more mindful of what is happening this
is
a health pandemic we are living in this
is a crisis
we have suicide rates that we've never
seen before among students
our businesses are shut down we must do
something to protect the american people
first
and we also must protect the migrants
but allowing our borders to be poorest
without the covet testing is again it's
a mistake
not only for the nation but for the
migrants trying to come here
it's dangerous for both americans
and migrants we deserve better than that
in america
our americans deserve better than that
and we must support
dr miller's bill and insist that there
is cova testing
before people migrants are released into
america thank you and i yield back
general ladies time has expired madam
speaker i reserve
gentlelady reserves the gentlelady from
california is recognized
adam speaker as difficult as the
situation
is at our southern border
we are addressing it
the biden administration has acted
and they've made progress
they have no illusions about how hard
it is because they inherited
a dismantle program
and to protect our own workforce they
have launched operation
vaccinate bow
in late january at the beginning of the
biden administration
less than two percent of our frontline
personnel were vaccinated
to date more than 25 percent
of our frontline personnel have been
vaccinated
that's leadership that's not avoidance
of the problem that we face
and with that i reserve gentlelady
reserves
the gentlewoman from minnesota is
recognized madam speaker i have no
further uh testifiers if
i am prepared to close if the gentlelady
from
california
i am prepared to close madam speaker
the gentlewoman from minnesota is
recognized thank you madam speaker in
closing
there is a crisis at our border whether
the democrats acknowledge it or not
our border patrol agents are overwhelmed
detention facilities
are way over capacity and covet 19 is
spreading
unchecked throughout this puts the
health of both individuals detained
and the border agents at risk we
currently require
negative cova tests to travel in the u.s
so why should the southern border be any
different
the border crisis is in a direct result
of the administration's lacks
immigration policy and it's putting our
communities at further risk
of contracting covenanting madam speaker
i urge a no vote on the previous
question and a no vote on the underlying
measure and i yield back the balance of
my time
the gentlewoman yields back the
gentlewoman from california is
recognized
madam speaker last week we passed a
historic american rescue plan
which set out a vision of who we are
as a nation we are
a country that can conquer this virus
a country that cares about eliminating
childhood poverty
and a country that is dedicated to
ensuring that
everyone everyone not just the rich
are able to emerge from the pandemic and
do better
the bills before us today are a
continuation
of this vision of a country
committed to doing better
for the people too many people in
america
live in fear fear because they are
not protected under the law but these
bills before us today
say no more the violence against women
reauthorization access to domestic abuse
survivors you are safe you are going to
be safe
h.j russ 17 which removes the deadline
for the ratification of the equal rights
amendment says to women
you are equal we are equal
the dream and promise access to dreamers
you too
can have a shot at the american dream
and the farm workforce modernization act
tells our farm workers you can do your
job
without fear of deportation h.r
1868 tells americans don't worry about
draconian cuts
let's focus on recovery madam speaker
the bills before us today will continue
the democratic congress work to do
better
by all the american people madam speaker
i urge
a yes vote on the rule and the previous
question
i yield back the most of my time and
move through the question
on the resolution the question is is on
ordering the previous question
on the resolution all those in favor say
aye
those opposed no the eyes have it the
previous question
is ordered the gentlelady from minnesota
is recognized
madam speaker i request to record a vote
the a's and nays
pursuant to section 3 s of the house
resolution 8
the yeas and nays are ordered pursuant
to clause 8
of the rule 20 further proceedings on
this question
are postponed
pursuant to clause 12 a of rule 1
the chair declares the house in recess
subject to the call
of the chair
you